fala pessoal que está aqui o nosso laser
cumprir o tempo cheguei à sua querida
nestas caixas com do mistério a opção
sobre oo o meu deus em nome de um
estrago é não vou embora agora só por
isso embora o número obtido a lei foi
bem feche boatos pessoal de quem fala é
o dark sejam muito bem vindos a mais 16
e os estragos de que mais um vídeo do
goleiro herói pois aqui mas não é este
um mais potente do que o que está dentro
desta caixa aqui mas já mostra jogos
mostra o primeiro primeiro vou fazer uma
coisa essencial à vida pedro não é
comida por cima muito valor ao óleo
chegava a comer bombons a melhor coisa
que vocês podem comer bem é o pessoal
conselho tutelar que eu não conheço não
pode ser os irmãozinhos manteiga de
amendoim contágio já sentir a mesma que
irá sim comida nem precisa esta nova
estudar nova consola vou ficar aqui um
pouco assim chega não caiu na minha mão
na boca eu não faço sempre na cozinha
com um problema menor
agora é só esperar assim em espelhinho
nem ganha pão ó galpão foram escritos em
folhas ouviram que poderia estar
ocupando a lei pois é só por um ponto
sim é tão média está em um time pode
fazer como eu quer por cada cinema
treinamento em algum lugar assim em
greve
bené documento finalmente novo começo
até o fim embora pessoal tal pegou a
chave na porta do shopping que dentro
desta caixa dessa aqui o tempo mas é
mais potente do mundo é mais do que tudo
tudo pessoal e cobrir em três dois um
vai o outro é muito grande é muito
grande diz o álbum só usou a lei mas é é
de continuarmos aqui o vídeo já sabem
inscreva se aqui no canal para tentar
chegar aos 3 mil inscritos muito rápida
quase e carrega também no cinema para
serem avisados tempo quando saí de novo
aqui no canal e já sabem disse temer o
vôo o aik pelo mega líquido e ele puxou
as tuas do olho aí é muito ruim duo
direito a atenção é o foco no clima
sério porque pelos vistos pois é bem
patente na procura o outro mas ele não
vai com a sua proteção e isso vai embora
só em dúvida o vermelho e depois apostou
sem afetar a visão sério meio de um
corredor também o laser ataque o
shopping a jovem com pilha o sul21 dos
filhos jesus pede alex é ainda mais
gostoso ver que um saquinho com cinco
cabeças tempo 5 ponto e essa é minha
parte favorita do laser é porque tem que
dar 15 clubes diferentes e para mim isso
é só um laser que o filho não se
pusermos de imagem nós vamos implementar
e seus componentes
ela é bem robusto é que fui tentar uma
lei muito grande e que isto me escutam
que não vou ganhar ainda vos pra e
postei aqui ponto que de onde saiu ilesa
eu tenho que o laser antigo e este ponto
é bem mais porque nem a inflação no país
o que eu acho que a queimar mas eu acho
eu acho que já sabem pessoal não façam
isso em casa bucco cara que um ou outro
lado proteçã ã o lapso ao estar aqui o
nosso laser um prepotente em 321 vai o
uh uh é muito fortalecido mude foi mais
calma eu sinto logo que o instantâneo na
mão olha isso nunca brinquei com escalas
em casa serviço que mesmo a lei para que
uma bala não foi 321 vai vou apontar o
brasileiro aqui na bola
olha aí tava até mesmo o lei tatu temem
olha só a cei fun
com isso a queimar muito e mesmo
potentes kleiza
olha aí já como é que ficou por aí
aumentar quase furada e você parar a
bola olha aí
só pagando por alguns fios rio
eu cortei abalando maio com laser meu
esquema muito reforça sua crença de que
isso vai sendo ele é tipo em um complexo
321 vai só ponto na cabeça e deu deu
muito rápido só vocês lembram quando eu
sair daqui meu durava muito e eu tinha
que encontrar um ponto de focagem certo
nicho não voltar a se unir dois ao mesmo
tempo para 321 vagas
o ovo o que acontece se orgular aqui
esta parte e fica muito maior o islã e
olha eu sou fica muito maior muito mais
porque não for acionado o impacto mas
não queima eu acho que eu vou pagar a
luz de vocês vão ver como é que
funcionam embora 321 vai e olhei se um
volume muito grande não só terá primeiro
que o filho do zé é um
é um hum eu sou star wars olha só quem é
o seu ponto de vista o projeto ilumina o
quarto tudo só vou experimentar as
criancinhas agora ok já coloquei
primeira cabeça 32 um vai e olha isso
fica muito louco vou contar com
aparelhos é erro tal pessoal sério
ilumina tudo o pigmento que se não cai
nessa segunda cabeça 3 de junho vai o
que é este aqui é quase o mesmo mas
falha muito mais
olha só como iluminar o quadro olha aí
tomar espectro automáticas e na cabeça
embora 321 pai está aqui é tipo um circo
onde é isso aqui é o conteúdo ainda
mantém mas tem mais círculos a volta é
muito louco ok 4 cabeça 321 vai pode
isso esta é uma risca não é um em star
wars ou qualquer uma destas de um minuto
quinta e última cabeça 321 vai colocar
aí está aqui precisa a primeira não é
nenhuma imagem do preço mais fácil que
por mini quadrados com com bolinhas
o pedófilo só tem pena porque de agora a
equipe pode experimentar o à noite então
se quiserem que os permitisse levar à
noite deixei muito aqui neste vídeo
porque os poucos que fazer mais coisas
boas à noite pra citar o pessoal quando
eu estou no quarto à noite iluminada o
quarto com o laser de miranda e deixem
lá e agora vamos tentar queimar mais
coisas por falta em que esta bola eu
acho que ela tem uma rápida porque ela é
tipo esponja não é bora lá 3 o joinvile
leis
eike - infelizmente é só tocar a bola e
já fica uma bolinha preta a igreja não
vai lhes já queimava logo eu não estou a
dizer é muito tenta ser o outro fazer
buraco está a fazer um buraco e olha só
o funk da silva
vamos fazer um teste aqui eu tenho que
um devedor de temperatura eu vou dar um
exemplo previa temperatura do outro mas
é fantástico esta sim é fantástico para
mim só sei cantar assim pra minha língua
34 33 34 é por aí vamos ver a estrutura
da mesa o trecho vai 2626 bem mas jamais
e agora vamos ver a temperatura do laser
seu plantar mesmo aprendi dentro do
laser será que muda
vou tentar aprontar a lei 32 graus 33
gol e começou a queimar só vocês viram
se o fundo quem cabe apontar as coisas
pressões
os dois lados entraram e curtir cuida
concurso com história e precisa andar
com um explica lá o everton vai ser
calma pessoal
atenção nunca faço isso o vila e um 38 e
39 em maio então isso tem quase 40 graus
só que só agora vou tentar fomentar um
balão eu já sei que o pleito parlamentar
entretenimento nos vão experimentar
primeiro amarelo porque o amarelo é uma
cor mais viva você está bem com lazer
completo e muito mais cura então vamos
limitar o primeiro gol encheu tudo
seguido e bora lá 321 vai não reinventou
logo vento alguns entendimento como
assim nem o segundo passo miudinho preto
mais longe ainda 321 vai até este já foi
um segundo mas também estava mais longe
sei se quero entender a dimensão agora
vamos tentar queimar ainda mais duro que
ponto as tic mais duro não um balão não
uma coisa esponja mas sim um fit a
convite de pina e expedito pereira bando
bem aqui e não lá pessoal laser contra
pedidos pneu em 321 vai ou o chaparro
como é que é possível só vocês vão ver
isso ilumina muito lindo ver mas não tá
mesmo a queimar a mesma que marcos
quiserem ver mais vídeos com isso trazer
outro potente comitê yahoo junte mais é
hoje eu tiver um comentário mais rápido
faça um vídeo dois é imagine só explodir
coisas com isso a solidão explodir por
aí
será que este laser é capaz de acelerar
esta bomba assim nunca mais vão precisar
de um zagueiro o fogo ea distância é
muito mais seguro só vamos estar agora
só vou tentar a selic se ela seguir vou
mandar lá profundo e bora lá 3211 vai
agora é só tentar acertar ele será que
vai ascender a itapuca fogo do pacífico
um rol o novo funcionou assim mas é
incrível mas o mais incrível que já
viveu
[Aplausos]
o brasil porque imaginamos lembrou
queria footbo número de pessoas com quem
manda e plantões book acha que escrevo
meu futuro pessoal nós vamos ficar
porque com este lírio olha espero que
vocês tenham gostado muito fácil e já
sabem que só se quiserem ver mais vídeos
com slayer que ultrapotente comentem e
hoje não consegui arranjar ninguém que
um filmaço portanto tem que ser assim
mais parado vídeo médio da próxima vez
com laser vai ser muito mais tempo
dinâmico e acho que já vou ter alguém
filmar então vou conseguir fazer
experiências muito mais lucas nossa mas
quiseram ver mais vídeos com laser
comentei arroz que deixou o vosso e mail
é que meus filhos já sabem também que a
equipe se manter depois viria
provavelmente não viram e aqui embaixo
vocês podem subscrever aqui no canal e
só fica quem vai até aproximar